alors mathieu mais vous avez aussi parce
qu'on va voir d'autres déclarations
je crois vous avez une déclaration
d'amour à faire aujourd'hui absolument
vous auriez de l'état vous un petit cor
et à cri non c'est vrai la sphère elle
est sincère à quelqu'un qui est ici avec
qui je vis presque une relation de
couple on va dire je dîne tous les
dimanches show avec je regarde les
grands prix de formule 1 avec quand
j'arrive chez lui son chien déjà me
reconnais dans l'escalier donc j'arrive
le mercredi on dîne également sur mon
part en vacances ensemble on se dit tout
et c'est vrai qu'il manque plus que le
sexe et ça pourrait peut-être terminée
comme ça parce que c'est une amie donc
cet ami évidemment c'est jean michel
maire oui j'ai 6 ans les émissions il ya
cinq ans maintenant
c'était un pote un copain maintenant
c'est vraiment un ami c'est beaucoup de
choses
et puis auprès de serre et de seconde
j'adore aussi la relation qu'il a par
exemple et qu'on voit pas tout le temps
à l'antenne avec sa fille wells et il
est très respectueux des femmes de sa
fille quand il m'appelle parfois pour me
dire en les larmes aux yeux mafia et sa
première année de médecine et qu'ils
partagent avec moi ça me touche beaucoup
donc voilà on sent quand je m'ennuie
jamais avec lui je reconnais qu'il
manque plus qu'une chose
[Rires]
excès de plusieurs des messages d'amour
comme ça
les vrais amis dans une vie normale
n'abandonne en afs urrugne voilà c'est
une main maximum à aider le quatrième
doigt de cette mam ce que j'avais trois
amis exceptionnel il est le 4e et ça a
pris cinq ans parce que l'amitié ça
n'est pas en 3d en 30 secondes ça a pris
cinq ans est pour l'instant c'est un ami
et puis la vie décidera il passe son
temps à s'évertuer à essayer de d'être
arrogant il sert alors que dans la vraie
vie c'est quelqu'un qui est formidable
et moi je dis qu'il y règne est connue
parce que c'est quelqu'un de très
sensible très fidèle amitié très drôle
voilà intelligent lyall albers de
l'image qu'on avait souvent de lui c'est
quelqu'un qui nous a manqué c'est
fantastique nice al'inverse de
l'imagination